about it now I had to restart the game
I got six viewers is that good for you
get 20 viewers what are you talking
about yes I mean Steve yeah you don't
have to always respond to everyone in
the same Arthur's we got coca-cola
captain coca-cola and Craig afros hey
where are we how do you play this mode
coke can you explain this to us
guys guys okay so so it's just it's the
time limit it's like round based it's
remember doubles where it like okay this
guy's behind the answer score yeah we
got him I see this says round score
we're up one I'd killed the guy what do
you mean you did it oh that we'll look
behind us you're gonna kill this guy
behind us I'm trying to follow a cold
blanking me yeah there's all that Coke I
need help back here man I'm here by
myself man we're dead we're dead what do
you guys doing man weird answer bad what
do you mean you're out here I need help
oh my god are they gonna go for heavy no
I'm going for this one over here or
you'll take it okay
god you're terrible with rockets you got
it this guy is the main ingredient I
didn't know your poor ass
where are you guys let's do let's talk
it out like what's going on with the
team here where's my god I got main
ingredient I got meaning yeah thank God
for that [ __ ] thank God oh we don't
you in here I thought we did thank God
for the what are you doing man well you
break it out you're okay this guy who is
this guy who's sinister sick Oh Maisie
on our team
oh my god you guys have a ring tell me
oh my god [ __ ] just got to [ __ ] I
need some help dude
where are you guys on and on and the
Euro junk oh no no please no no no
please I'm with you I'm with eight his
her Greg hey Greg Hadley says what's up
Steve big fan of the Steve oh yeah
thanks for coming there's one guy in the
corner to your right coke is the best
it's the best one me and CB are in the
same room it's greatness it's pure
greatness
so you tuned in to coax Episode II went
up a weight division it's he's gonna
kick ass his next fight we fight Mexico
I have no idea either
yeah no idea but it's at 170 so okay
playing with us and we have the sinister
guy he's I know I told you look who's
the number one coke what do you got to
say oh what's going on better it's not
KD and those are way
it's not kidding even if I want to
everything he'll just say you got Craig
if you ever got more kills than me and a
better KB dude I will give you props
it wasn't happen once you make $100 back
right you got it I got a bit on Soul
Calibur that's all I'm betting on oh
yeah see that's where's confident Oh
she'll just get [ __ ] up Katy
yep you talk about work that's what
happens we gotta finish the game you
don't know it's not happening for me
good we won we won the first no we
didn't do I lost I lost you very
severely I lost some we know I severely
love okay shot - god damn better Devils
I don't know he's out of town maybe arks
draft Ark staff come and watch out our
staffing other dudes got some [ __ ]
with them you give that heavy Craig you
gettin that heavy yeah okay where you
going now you're just gonna stand there
and we're gonna do it together or what's
the deal no Steve's on one night deed
he's ready I know
yes he's ready I like this what do you
mean you like it
these are playing like crazy you're mine
357 did you see Steve's 357 Steve I
gotta say I forgot I forgot to tell you
this Steve it was like maybe a week and
a half ago yeah your brother did your
brother did a show yeah what the [ __ ]
was it called what was it called
it was the splitting up together so tune
in Monday night
no I know okay
I know I know that no okay no this was
an old
okay
laughs forcibly I don't know why it was
in a white room yeah it was called like
talking or something yeah talking yeah
that was you talk Channel yeah he
doesn't have it when when right but yeah
I watched that the little little flip
are you on there yeah and I was dying
because i doing look no no because you
do look the exact same you you look well
he's but you can tell he's younger
yeah for sure I was definitely not first
show but you're younger
yes exactly the same you're just the
same like get your the same got like
everything you say you you know is on
point with what you would say right now
oh yeah we look a little older yeah you
don't are sure good job we're having a
competition now so Craig took first
round coke took second round and now
we're havin coke is the best but I don't
know about tonight cuz Craig's on fire
Craig's on fire
and you'll learn you'll see okay you
follow down dude I'm following you guys
okay yeah they got the idea aggressive I
find us I don't need to hurt scope with
the graviton land Steve blah blah blah
oh why you making fun of that gun dude
does man it's cheap it's a cheating gun
thanks for leaving me guys I will say it
I will say I hate the annual what's up
coach on two three one I don't use aunty
I can't get this heavy I'm not used to
looking heavy anti OB
oh I punched it oh my god dude
oh this guy suppressed me dude oh what a
[ __ ] dick he suppressed me dude how's
uh how's the salad tossed and Pikachu
shut up man it's been okay all so hot in
here and like this is weird you should
be in here with us
uh I I know I know after your match I'll
join
what if you just want to turn it on uh
2029 oh my god this guy blew me up oh my
god oh my god shotgun yep no you don't
are we winning
come on how we doing good we're tied
we're tired no Craig watch off oh [ __ ]
and put a bomb right next to him okay
got some comments here these guys are
giving us the gun do you want there are
no sucky weapons oh I got that guy thank
you
I got tapeworm thank you see what
happened there hey that's my heavy I
can't serve any boys get that get that
heavy I got it I got that missed
I didn't oh but that guy shot me from a
mile away with the Uriel's I thought
that [ __ ] was Lindsay are we doing good
what's the score we got are we okay one
down we need one killer yeah we need one
guys okay we're tired guys
oh all that get back Craig don't go in
Craig I didn't go in no I'm not you did
go in you survived yes but you went
right in do you see that hit up with my
vigilance wing there you see what I did
I'm not doing great I think it's wrong
to negativity back up Craig
oh I got this another guy oh there you
go dude you did it Steve Steve you
you're the MVP that round
oh well Steve look at that Steve yeah
dude I'm [ __ ] killing it rounder
sinister was the best know you Thank You
Craig you get in there too far dude
Craig what are you doing in there kill
them dudes Craig what happened there I
took out three dudes but guilty okay uh
Rob Ford zero cuz of that
aha that was beautiful go that was
Buddha must know he killed Ethan no way
this [ __ ] guy main ingredient he says
um Steve's audio isn't included in Craig
stream ah alright when we've only break
Steve no audio
[ __ ] me dude that's what someone said
yeah thanks for cutting me out Craig
Jesus oh my god did you hear what he
said
no thanks for coming yeah I gotta add
your audio what do you mean yeah you
caught me out dude no you come on oh
yeah I know I told you that now I'm just
getting farmed no you didn't if they're
telling me they can't hear you an ice
cream
what do you mean I don't know I
anybody's watching my street it's okay
no one watches your stream anyway I know
that's all we needed no yeah I know
that's what I do I thought I was in just
go to the party and click the add your
audio sky keys Your Honor he's got the
under nades dude Oh Mike went on and on
we're getting lit oh I made it
it's a picture I'm Steve's face that I
that I am screenshotted a new live
stream Double Down and said love and
mercy keep kids oh [ __ ] tie this damn
guy get that heavy get the heavy do it I
wasn't here I want that word
how did that mess up dude like it went
right through like I saw we're tied oh
[ __ ] what is that all that's our guy
that's you now sinister he's killing it
oh [ __ ] crying back said Klong bad guys
oh man I got some snark good job good
job Steve I I did get at the air and I
got to fusion off okay that's two
McLovin is good to see Steve playing
games
Oh Steve
you brought it home six-six brother yeah
lucky on those main ingredient kills I
just I just had a commit and just hold
down the trigger there yeah let me get
in this put me in go come on what are
you doing you got the tattoo you're not
gonna play with us or what I'm ready to
play I've been watching videos I just
knew this camp dude I've been watching a
butt wipe and on the other guy on on
YouTube they do two V fours these guys
are awesome announcement June I think
it's yeah June 5th they're gonna do the
livestream for what I believe is going
to be go to go to the park okay
I'm here now okay thanks buddy norther
what's up tada miss the Mon what's up -
lately
what's up - make love in you guys
because they're our leader okay guys you
just use you're always not talking to me
all right you guys good to invite ya I'm
just with you Craig that's it I'm just
me and you where's Bobby he should be
playing - Bob doesn't play Dustin just
to just to get this out here my brother
does not play destiny - he's on far cry
5 at the moment yeah one day we'll get
Bobby back
what's up Chuckie monster 8:05 what's up
- tag out Cookie Monster is it for you
let me just keep saying I'm joining the
fire team but I'm already in ICU you
guys want to do a run of trials just for
fun or no I'm down for whatever you want
to do we can run do trials
you mean loser trials well Gavin says
it's too cold it's hot in here yes it is
here we go
what up - being with the family people
oh my god
yet we're gonna try to
we got twitch one that's right all right
we're doing trials how we do do Milton 9
you know it all football
steve has Lionel launching I have a
vinyl Monty I got a hang-up Steve gave
me I have vinyl yes fine yes there's
about five people that's a lot Steve
says get that sub work on that cosmic
I'm working on the keep talking until
you guys stop talking I'm gonna keep
talking because I've been cut I've been
cut into about three to the it's a
special occasion and I said I got some
classic winner during school to
celebrate with Steve if everybody would
shut up you want to put one in yet we're
putting it in I just spit out my
Gobstopper for you it's oh it's it's
funny Craig because once I said that
Steve got real excited again it bugged
out the game just try again
you're even aware do it without
screaming how do i dip without spitting
or I just contain it in my mouth and I
enjoy the the wintergreen flavors this
is gonna be either really good or really
bad and you know what I'm talking about
cuz we got our asses kicked last week
here's your house that sawdust and going
you doing good
what would it mean doesn't gonna like
this map I'm on my job bro stop talking
about my job
how's it going great
I saw my mom let's say that packet like
I'm packing a dip right now but I
already have one in oh this is I can't
be doing this on stream that's crazy
wait what's this closed off there's a
girl named Lindsey in the chat who says
she's from Iowa
there you go coke it's probably Lindsey
[ __ ] that's not are you sure and
she's a twitch Prime member what does
that mean it means you link to your
Amazon Prime account with twitch cuz
Amazon bought twitch TV yeah it's good
so then you get like benefits and all
this other stuff it's the games now I
use I'll use Amazon but Amazon is gonna
take over the world
okay machi but we currently don't have a
Booker or a booking agent or a manager
so we're trying to get one so if there's
anyone out there in the twitch world
that will manage us or book us holler
okay long she forever yeah we have you
know I try my best Arthur there's only
about ten people there but I tried we
had the crappiest timeslot at grizzly
310mm
yeah I was like preaching time somebody
called you this is our team Craig with
this one shoulder Niles well you got the
helmet nice yeah this one bucket
audience a warm hostile miners no
courage that that mortal bear
there's an over sale during slam a um
have you seen the new um trials of the
nine weapons very good yeah new ones the
new ones oh no he's got a graviton Lance
we got two graviton Lance's oh no we're
in trouble let's go um I'm going out
lightning patty oh no no no no no no no
we're going inside we're going inside
inside first yep
my game audio's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
all right I don't need it beside here in
there guys been pushing this my bad I
didn't listen to you cook okay what do I
do here just try and get a kill cause I
just got devastated sorry guys we're not
good my [ __ ] game audio's sorry
McLovin [ __ ] I can't hear the game oh
so we got no kills well me we're going
outside
oh really okay we won't follow us today
and we went outside every time I'm
inside to defend me I got one I got one
more there we go that one oh there's one
more on that body
that's my grenade I'm setting he's
getting roses
what are we doing here you just just was
mm-hmm
[ __ ] he got me just playtime playtime
what's out behind you Steve behind you
Steve just keep them off just keep them
off heavy heavy I'm dead dude I'm bad
dude I tried right I think we got it yep
we got it we got it yeah good job okay
we won okay great so is your favorite
whoa damn Steve's good no dude don't do
that right now I bet I am scared I was
inside action because that's where
you're going yeah because this this
they're gonna come up this right side
here okay I'm with you brother I'm with
you brother I'm right here they're not I
think they're gone outside yep hold on
go around go around
hey cover don't get shot pull all the
way around are you for real [ __ ] there
they're behind us that came to came they
[ __ ] we were on the wrong plot we
were in the wrong place wrong time
do it the wrong way
all right should we go outside of you
yeah yeah go outside outside it's kind
of it's easier not to get flanked
oh [ __ ] what they're eight four of them
there's four of them right in front of
you
what above you I know so sorry guys okay
we could do this dude we doing something
wrong
every [ __ ] I keep getting picked off him
about I bet they're gonna come in now
they're gonna switch it up that's what I
think yeah yeah I mean like I just like
to start defending out in here that way
we're all close and we can move together
there's a guy up nope up up top they're
here they're here all right I got one I
got one buck they're inside man they're
peeking down just Steve don't watch the
hallway
okay guys I need to get Coco I should be
using graviton Lance get him up ah no
it's me and coke now what - God dang
these guys did a real good play oh man I
know I'm sorry rude dog I'm not good I'm
just having fun
I know I know rude dog I'm so sorry
Wow whoa
and that [ __ ] worm Haas helmet dude
he was dead yeah I shoot him like 20
times I keep giving alright
I say outside look let's no let's go
inside inside let's all push this left
this left hallway but follow me don't
don't stop and don't look out that's
right up hold on there's an art staff
behind us this guy he's gonna that's a
warm-up that's a warm-up we need it says
you're good just bad game Thank You
Damas I got my own I almost stopped
alright let's wait for them to make a
move then all right they're coming
inside yeah jumping inside tether
tethered the inside of that if you can
Steve I don't have it yet oh
all right oh my god cuz you sent it at
the end of the round we're all dead
you're like he's tethered we're all dead
alright cosmic I know I know
alright Lau's our warm up doesn't warm
up that was our warmup you know it you
got to take these broken wings take
these broken start that song yeah song
in macGruber
the sex scene and macGruber movie I need
to see that Steve if you haven't seen
that dude I want to movie because me my
buddy had to kill time you know there's
nothing out we went to it wasn't do this
for like a week yes sorry dude I was
dying I was [ __ ] I don't see make
that [ __ ] was hilarious dude it's got
its got a Val Kilmer in it
I love Val Kilmer I'm a fan of this yeah
yeah he's he's the bad guy
he's [ __ ] awesome in it too it says
we need Eric Griffin someone said we
need Eric Griffin how do I fix my audio
dude it's not coming through the system
I've been my god this is a nightmare
okay so we need to go on the outside are
we gonna go on the outside or the inside
let's we gotta keep let's talk about it
alright let's keep it simpler just for
us pp brains we need to do all we need
to do the only the only reason we're
getting getting screwed it's because
their team shot in the [ __ ] out they're
staying really close you guys you guys
try just try it this round even if even
if I know you guys like to like you're
aiming the lanes there's no wrong with
that but like for me to do anything I
have to get close I have to push
I got me I'll be right by your side
brother do you want me to be like when
we're not when I'm running yeah I'm with
me like deal what the only
I shoot the wrong target I'm not
shooting at the same targets as you and
that's the the problem yeah
here's here's the thing Steve like don't
even look at you don't look so much at
your radar just follow where I go yeah
there is no well there is no radars yeah
just sheep what I'm shooting and here's
the thing if you're shooting another
target because there's multiple targets
as long as we have Pikachu and Craig if
there's all four of us they can't they
can't kill all of us they're gonna have
any times getting the same things gonna
happen to them they're targets but if
they have if they have four on two we're
gonna get we're gonna lose the ten shot
we're not we're not gonna win Kirby
chill out
he's laughing at he's barking at Craig's
character there that helmets scaring my
dog Craig my hunter is looking pretty
sexy I know cruising the the ghosts of
the bones people Kirby
these are gonna be these are just lost
we gotta bring it let's go I'm ready
let's go I got some Sausalito Turkey and
me dude okay what are we doing here
these guys are real good huh oh yeah so
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait all
right they're doing inside you can hear
him no no they're going outside behind
us
I hear one better outside
I'm so sorry Craig this mitt chief is
really good man woohoo yeah my dogs are
not helping nice oh my god it's team
coca-cola all day
nice try nice try nice right good job
we'll see you guys so I can't hear the
game my game Mike my audios [ __ ] yeah
after this game we should let Craig fix
it what wolf excellent weapon set let's
go patio outside
it's got Commons right right oh my god
dude Oh Lord Kirby you're not helping
dude seriously please don't do that
all you guys don't do that dosa zone
come to me come to me I need that guy
though yeah I need to revive to you I
need to revive to you I'm getting I'm
getting Steve okay Pikachu kinda don't
poke don't poke let's get the guy behind
us okay what you guys that let's talk
I'm confronting I'm doing talk it out no
way our two are down I'm getting heavy
I'm getting heavy right now no I'm not
there's a guy over here on patio I need
help yeah 4000 um coke we need coke up
dude oh behind us behind us behind us
wow oh god dude I'm so sorry guys
oh hey Shh cuz we got like two pics in
the beginning
all right what if we get two picks like
I said just follow me even even if you
see a guy aiming down
just follow me just run run with me stay
really close I'm with you I'm with you
we got him we got two down we got two
down stay with me
there's there's there's another guy
outside yep I got Craig there we go all
right one left
come on I'm with Craig here he's right
on me all right we got a Craig get
battle this I'm going okay I got it
don't worry
[Music]
oh my god did we do it we did it
okay that's that's teamwork there we
listen to you coke we listen to you
let's do it again let's just listen to
the Eric and he's got it nice job Arthur
all right so let's let's go inside
follow me there's gonna be one up here
[ __ ] get your health back card yep I got
one okay he got with me push with him
there's one in here he's in the side
there Steve
he's behind you still owe he got me I
treated it they traded they traded I'm
dead ahh all right I'm sorry it's my
father head sorry it doesn't help I
can't hear anything
except for you guys all right same thing
when we defend here all right
yep and be quiet be quiet cuz I can hear
him jump all right there inside one's
goin patio ones trying to come across
yeah all right there inside inside all
right so Steve I'm coming to you yep
there's two hurt over but me there's one
there's another guy down there flanked
us he's right above you peek at you
right there oh man right there
sorry guys I'm not really sit the rate
there no radar things are kind of
messing me up to I don't I don't know
where we got a let's go outside
got one that's okay Tommy at this
graviton I'm down I'm certain throwing
up a shield okay this guy is um he he's
come in right by my body's behind you
guys there we go nice now let's just
hold this zone yeah you see anybody
Peaks now he got me with heavy he's
gonna go that's everybody
wait I [ __ ] dude I didn't how was it did
he revived oh my god I can't hear did
somebody call it out yeah I didn't hear
him revive or see it [ __ ] man okay I got
a reset Patti I gotta have some audio
this is ridiculous
alright guys don't be afraid to use your
supers either cuz we gotta win this
get the [ __ ] out of here
that one where they I could talk to me
I'm dead I don't see anybody there it
just get a real live grade I'm trying
dude [ __ ] I care all right let's fix
Craig [ __ ] yeah Craig pictures that let
me fix my [ __ ] let me see what's going
on I'm at the reboot real quick give me
a second
prismatic what is that
okay there it is okay I got it now I had
to restart the game no no hard feelings
no I mean I had to I rebooted the system
but it didn't work I had to like quit
out and restart the game you got off you
got a heart you got a hard quit the game
or the listening to that's what I did
all right oh it's all working now up
bird and you must sign in and I'm ready
to go I'm gonna go back to some old
school [ __ ] here gonna go to the double
deuces okay okay
no I bet I've been doing double hand
kids no I put them on on and on on and
on thick thick thick
what is Steve doing Steve trying to
scare himself he's he's messing with his
lady with his bone face or yours Steve
would be great as the modern Skeletor
damn you he-man
I am Skeletor okay we all we all good
what's the four days you're the movie
dude deep sigh solo what you think Steve
I didn't see solo
I did not see so what did you down with
Kathleen what's the best not like I say
down with Kathleen Kennedy that's all I
got to say okay I feel you I'm excited
for hereditary I'll watch hereditary in
a few weeks
do you have the screener for hereditary
no I don't have that yeah okay come on
Craig where's the hook this I thought so
it was okay oh yeah you saw this one
here we go no no we're good
if I heard that the robot wakes I heard
the robot makes like like modern jokes
that are wack yeah I mean I don't know
what that was that a spoiler we're doing
trial with a mine crack okay hold on
hold on
I'm just waiting the stream hold on are
you though I'm starting broadcasts over
words okay I got my might out now okay
make sure your audio is included that's
the one Steve yeah it is included I just
look she's the producer Star Wars
Kathleen Kennedy yeah not a fan of
Kathleen Kennedy
what about Kathleen Turner do you like
her Oh someone's asking me oh myit's
asking me to Maude so why nothing
someone wanted to say something rude and
chat okay so I got my audio back so I
can I can finally like now we're gonna
start winning watch coke deer [ __ ] well
that's not winning yeah it's like I
couldn't hear guys it was a handicap
this are you kidding me if you can't
hear where they're shooting from that's
a huge handicap I didn't know it's where
they're coming should I turn my volume
louder so I could listen she have a
headset yeah I can't hear like Coco
could hear them jump around I can't hear
that stuff yeah you guys just up your
game audio are you talking oh yeah yeah
you have a good answer
okay I turned it up two notches all
girlfriends getting on oh boy here we go
guys did it it
these guys are sounds good are you sure
said I like that helmet Steve yeah it's
cool it's called the warm mosque
I wish Pikachu had cooler stuff are you
for real
you hang on me I'm like that could you
switch this scout rifle yep these guys
have the same shaders oh no we're in
trouble and this is a different team we
can [ __ ] him up
oh no he's wear the same helmet is me no
no all right let me focus let's good
that's good okay where we go where do we
go so let's wait to hear this movie
outside I think no inside inside all for
our inside or inside where we're inside
we're inside inside of where B is or
they'll get hit
nope died on me
behind us where is everybody where is
everybody there get it get him up get
him up damn Oh cuz I had those guys nice
job Stevie that fried man
which way'd coke let's go outside
Baron idle back oh there's a guy in back
here he's hurt
god damn you oh my god graviton man oh
my god oh my god oh no we're not doing
good sorry guys we're trying oh my god
is it our tactics what is it is there
are guns or is it our tactics what is it
these guys are just heme we're just not
we're a team - man get in - yeah we're
not doing team shots or what yeah it's
like we're lost we don't even know
what's happening I got one there's
another one out there he's hurt he's
there's one outside he's hurt he's guys
held back oh dude I couldn't get him up
oh I'm sorry Arthur I try to get you up
no that's okay
you don't always have to focus on
getting me up well beyond your coke nope
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Craig Craig go go get him Craig on get
crap oh I mean it was kind of hard they
already know like the old days
no Chad says that Craig get that twitch
girl no yeah of course
oh yes he did dude outside I'm watching
our flank I'm no pond us well that guy
not die come on I got him
I just didn't understand it like he
bounced back and some other Stoll was
alive
he's on heavy that side that nice
Pikachu there's one guy way out there
still he revived [ __ ] [ __ ]
come on man they're waiting get back get
that prick
Oh No thank you okay give me up when you
guys can you get me up now yeah where
are you I'm right he got me up thanks
guys hi Anika Chu that was good Pete we
got one all right let's go
good job are there up Peaks which is
good we just got a place tomorrow have
someone watch her back okay I'm gonna
watch the right outside in the tunnels
mm-hmm I heard him outside there's one
inside one inside needs to come to me
coming
that guy's so [ __ ] heard that [ __ ]
[ __ ] leaning down he's in the middle
by heavy he's getting heavy coat behind
you I can't see nothing man
Thank You Arthur Steve oh I know I
couldn't even he wouldn't even let me
get up he had a shotgun ammo oh dude
thanks an all-time-high smart we could
still win wow they're all there but
we're dead
my bad Steve OHT all down there t-bag
eNOS come on are we going outside inside
where we going going outside I got
Golden Gun okay
they're inside yep no they're all in the
water push my coke push wake up I can
I'm hurtle and getting it from like
three angles my god this guy [ __ ]
slammed their phase and all their [ __ ]
Dan damn it let's go let's give it
another try guys so we're just kind of
getting used to each other yeah one more
round
okay one more round okay my guess is
gonna come inside in your supers guys
got tether he could choose now it's time
to use your [ __ ] use it oh [ __ ] storm
chance yeah yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] either
[ __ ] meaty [ __ ] cooking [ __ ]
he's so hurt nice coke I have my arrow
should I use it yeah you must use it
with tether though mm-hmm Steve you
gotta shoot it as soon as you get out
there cuz they're gonna win
[Music]
I got it nice anyways anyways this slam
nice good job Steve whoa nice generating
guys yeah guys are killing it oh [ __ ]
he's total that was good yeah let's go
inside let's go inside
uh-oh I hear something I hear something
I hear something
follow me beet soup follow me I'm with
you now I got one getting the res he's
in back where's the [ __ ] oh there you go
brother
there you go brother yes well let's go
let's get it you're going inside
yep one out there ones outside up one on
the side yeah you got
yeah don't cry find revive Kok if you
have a chance where is he he's near now
I can't get nice tooth you might have
time to get it if you let's do one more
I mean I still have fun I don't care
yeah Craig are you hearing
you know you playing that round I give
it to you you don't know so good he's
giving me [ __ ] happens here can we kick
out Pete
Gavin Pikachu for Gavin just kidding
little salty huh saltine cracker by
Gavin yes we were if we want by KD I
think we got a kick crank yeah but if
you went by a who's cooler then you got
a kill ah you turning against me was
that Craig chat it is not chat who said
it was the next guest on Steven Levy Oh
Eli from living legends this went this
week so tune in Eli family life and
living legends yeah he's dropping a new
album to support it
he's a great artist Pikachu almost made
it out you almost made it on this show
oh wow
I mean okay Arthur you want to get on or
why I Gavin yeah definitely sometime
maybe next time we're gonna have to talk
about the you're gonna have to give me a
little review yeah you've been using it
you've been using it I get nobody
responses you have he used he used it
the first hour you gave it to him that's
really what to Craig's house yeah he was
well and he was bailing away had himself
amazing did it feel good or what
interesting okay all right did I get you
some oils you got some oils right no I
had to buy some photos working with like
[ __ ] no you think it felt like like
the person Pikachu no laughs fair enough
you're gonna bark again or what though
we're gonna win this match all right we
I feel good about this I got the auntie
Opie there we go so you got to be close
the ante up right yeah okay
you just gotta play lame because you
left the invisible you know yeah you go
in burst them good vis they can't see
you hopefully there's a teammate next to
you and then you know they team straight
and they're dead
that's what happens that's why antelope
so good because it's a quick quick kill
time it's done really good range for
submachine gun too you can use it medium
range let me take a look yeah the range
is again I get a boost on rate Oh cuz I
nice work there
yeah I'm fun cragger what's up me again
being kind of quiet I'm having a great
time we're all here no you really have a
good time to be sarcastic are you really
hard to get done I'm trying not telling
you coming out - oh you are when cold
poke are you staying at Jesse's place
this time oh yeah banana boy can come
again I already talked to Steve's girls
who said it's okay she's gonna go else
we're gonna start the bed yep we're
gonna do top bottom so these guys look
at them dude Jade rabbit the last breath
I haven't seen that
I'm not intimidated let's go are we
going outside inside yeah where are you
going stop
let's go inside let's go inside come
with you dude mmm-hmm I'm with you
brother
yeah nice ah I hurt that guy he's right
outside there with my grenade can I get
him behind you Steve yeah the Sun get
this less damaged scene careful Steve
geneviève out back up back up back up
oh my god we almost had those guys oh we
have to be more we have to be aggressive
when we kill them we got air in my in my
defense I was with you the whole time
bribe I got that first guy and then I I
had that grenade on the second but he
backed the [ __ ] up
they're coming in the tunnel I got one
outside that's my grenade I just want to
keep him back there we go
one here we ready to go alright hey I
get that heavy get my rest get my rest
yeah there you go there we go there we
go what are you there we go
told you get it hell yeah I see you I
see you Craig inside outside
oh so I like it okay
we're setting let's try outside outsides
easier to cover there's a guy out here
couple her doors inside I'm pushing he's
hurt watch our flank
ah he's right above us he's right there
yep nice beyond abused he [ __ ] me up
though behind behind Stevie oh yeah yeah
nice try nice try it's okay it's okay
okay yeah we gotta watch our plan is
going inside again or one more defending
let's call it out immediately what we're
gonna go next no Bock they might go
outside cuz they took us there
yeah back in the tunnel ones in the
tunnel
oh my god one that downside I got shot
let's try to get that res didn't happy
oh [ __ ] shot they're peeking my resin
out my girls
okay once coming inside
he's on my body oh my god they're so
aggressive dude oh my god good grenade
they're [ __ ] right but let me yeah
I'll pushed on there behind me I did it
now we didn't get it I'm sorry I'm not
playing good guys they're just they're
surrounding me personally their
surrounding doctor where do they where
do they first hit you was that the
middle yeah the middle are we going one
except I like going inside Craig I'm
behind you don't want to go take Tom
wall grenade up there crazy fan I don't
have it here is not a nice clothes
inside hurt [ __ ] I didn't get the melee
attack on him
I need help but there you go there you
go baby go baby
good job guys
[ __ ] they are switch up guns should just
work right quick what about your minor
you're good with your minor no no I
think maybe vigilance thought I can't
switch anywhere now Kyle come with you
Cole come with you yep I'm fine good job
[ __ ] who stammers all three out there
not one
you gotta rest good back Steve I got
real ones on my body he's put hammer and
Hammer to run Craig oh my god I should
have [ __ ] arrow dumb know I got my
arrow I don't don't worry about it used
it so this is what we're gonna do Steve
you got a tether right yeah okay we're
going to let's go inside yeah if if we
if we can set it tether the spot even
account but he's there that's only if
there's nobody there they're on the side
one down there we go
should I said it yep get me lock there
we go
I didn't mean I did not mean the super
[ __ ] tether right I killed someone
no just oh we won the round whatever oh
sorry dude use that panic Errol I just
we've wasted that's okay [ __ ] oh okay
here behind us that one nice nice boots
they're playing outside they're playing
outside play outside well I think ones
in a tunnel what's in a tunnel I got one
they got the rez going to ongoing tunnel
one want to jump in oh my god that was
aggressive he's being aggressive man oh
my god I got him where's the word the
rest there by my corpse yeah good good
job brother good job slam we got a win
wound inside it go inside you played
terrible outside they got storm though
just remember the guy with storms yeah
hey wait come to me coming coming coming
don't peek that link they're not here
they're not here you want to set it
yes I didn't forget it government Cohan
cover me
not a peg on Donna
all right someone got me down here
someone is picking up heavy yep you got
him you got him get him get him get a
website ones on site he's on my dead
body
coming to you guys did you get up Koch
yep get out of there there you go I'm
down there pushing you guys just go ones
defusing what's the fusing so we got it
we have to win this round we lose
outside I think no the bat just keep
attacking got that guy hey fall back -
Sean out there I don't know what he's
doing
rather say who said it I was like oh we
got time we got time hold on go yet I'm
just gonna [ __ ] with them a little I'm
not going out there there we go ice up
behind me he's hurt he's hurt
oh he got heavy shoot him shoot him
Oh
thank you go let's go let's go [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I can't get out there I got him oh no
they got it oh my god we did least we
didn't get completely stomp good call
know what I'm saying
those close if we had had that match now
you guys did good get it real good
good job peace good everybody did good
except for me but good job guys good job
coke because we didn't waste all of her
super I've got one around I think I
can't believe he got that I thought you
definitely got him yeah yeah I like to
save my slam to get more guys but I had
no choice with that one game cuz he
slammed Steve might like to either slam
him or we lose God oh so close so I dug
dug the Sun shot that game is that a
good guy Sun shot sure to make about it
it's pretty good but it's gonna be way
better when next week when that catalyst
comes out hey dude it's the next week
that is Eric Oak is the guy from the
episode who got there
come on guys you guys could do it I know
we didn't do it though so thanks for
watching still we're just having fun I
mean we are so close
we could have had it take just a game
we'll just take it as a team-building
exercise that's all team-building kind
of want to switch to something not storm
cholera but I don't know why don't you
do Don blame another that's a good
neutral neutral game there at the Dom
blade okay just stick with what you used
to do yeah yeah whatever you did well
you should definitely practice that Dom
blade I heard it's good you could like
jump in the air yeah yeah yo Coco much
weight DBA 29 is we got a record that
just be the new opening for Duffy please
turn off the music
don't tell me what to do okay that's
what are you treacle Jesus Christ okay
chica always plays music okay this is a
new game guys let's just you know start
fresh these are same dudes okay really
really mm-hmm yeah let's we have to beat
them we have these guys with me more so
yeah we have to beat these guys I know
we can be pregnant okay you know what
I'll switch the graviton next game also
to the graviton you're doing good kills
I think cried should use the vigilance
though I think he's better with that
yeah yeah yeah after this game switch I
it's a five burst all right we already
know where we're going
we are knowing it depends on what
whether we're defending it's just cuz
this is a slower shot even though it's
more powerful it's slower that's the
price you're screen black ya know they
want a plan C beam us they just be no
they're probably like oh we're gonna
lose this time
no maybe they don't want it okay we
gotta do it good good
we have to win now if we lose again
we're never streaming again I know this
guy joined him though right now
now you can thank you nice coke oh [ __ ]
I thought that was a grenade there we go
nice outside
oh my god dude you got all the kills oh
you and Craig I think you know I'm just
on my own I was I got an SS yeah we got
assists really well I mean I shot the
guys got the kills no there guy loaded
back in he was lying out but he he'd
loaded back and some installed how come
is stalling right now I'm [ __ ] up this
is loading back in that's why yes you
got that [ __ ] I didn't know you
could do that don't want you how you're
out well no they changed well look they
have a thing now never change when you
like out it gives you a chance to like
like you're the tribe's guy in the
middle there army they post
goddamnit got me oh I didn't know I was
last okay I got stuck in out I got stuck
in a [ __ ] pulse Nate go check outside
I've a feeling they're gonna switch it
up they're out there
Oh yep yeah I'm is he's gone inside
though they're pushing inside coming
around right right tunnel yeah right
down got one shirt behind me but Rosie
it's right there
[ __ ] how they get that rebar so fast
nice big - I'm getting hit from two
angles yeah they're all inside a second
there you go Pikachu get me up if you
can't beep nice all right he's naked you
know he got it right there [ __ ] kill him
do not got him going on I'm just
following you guys around I'm not sorry
guys are not playing good I don't know
what's going on you know you're playing
great let's go inside hey hey hey
outside outside outside get any suit
yeah
yep we're clear I'm setting it cover me
watch the flight
he's there he's going around the
right-left I'll get him on the left all
the way back
I got a nice crib Arthur don't go too
far on me
uh-huh he got me we got it behind me
what yeah pika cheeks nice dude let's go
let's go let's get it oh my god
there's no Craig yeah lucky which we've
gone now inside you think let's I think
they might go inside I'm gonna wait I'm
gonna be alright no ice nope they're
going back outside all right all right
[ __ ] he's hurt Oh should've had that
[ __ ] guy
he's inside behind you coke it's coming
in behind you mmm - ah double-teamed
yeah do it Peaks find you behind you the
time I could have come all of a man [ __ ]
they were all near each other inside
your ego and inside inside this thing
pushed left Craig got behind you they
went outside I'm setting in
there's someone out there crack yeah
he's hidin on Pikachu oh my god he
flanked me Craig be careful another
one's going tunnel another one's going
tunnel another one's going inside
hammers I got stuck at least two to the
you say Miami Slammers [ __ ] I got great
thank you I'm just gonna pee I'm just
gonna beat this hold on there outside
outside outside really oh yeah three of
them gold and gun you got em good yep
wait for the gold this guy got me good
this golden guy nice Pikachu okay can
someone get me up I don't know where
you're at
nice Pikachu just ditch them yeah come
to us there you go you have your armor
revives yep
yes yes I got my arrows still I got my
arrow Pikachu
nice job Peaks he could you step it up
yeah Lucas is killing it there we go
do that next round I'm gonna go patio I
got Golden Gun I'm gonna come from the
side all right nobody's here set it
pikachu set it
I'll set it all right you're setting
he's got it just cover him cover always
blocked this door I'm gonna wait for him
to turn flank
I'm gonna stay over here pop my Goldie
just see him back here yeah he's right
by the heavy right where I am
once logged Adam how's that guy not dead
so die yep okay so whatever one other
person Steve Steve Steve yeah just just
wait that's time set it let him set it
got one outside
let him set it let him set it so come
back here don't don't engage them
there's two of them outside it's time
that tester tell me when come to us
because they're set in that patio okay
go around the goal all the way around
and then set it Oh dad he got me down we
got him we got him don't do that
he almost made me [ __ ] don't bother
me all right yes Kirby we won dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]